une première vague englouti le littoral
une seconde lui succède et emporte tout
sur son passage
nous sommes en thaïlande au lendemain de
noël
en 2004 un séisme a frappé au large de
l'île de sumatra d'une magnétude de 9,1
c'est le tremblement de terre le plus
puissant jamais enregistré depuis 1960
la terre s'est soulevé et des vagues de
17 mètres de haut en raser de la carte
des dizaines de villages en quelques
heures des centaines de milliers de
personnes sont mortes en indonésie en
inde au sri lanka en thaïlande et dans
neuf autres pays
quinze ans plus tard le souvenir du
tsunami est toujours vif
cette mère thaïlandaise a toujours très
peur je veux aller vivre ailleurs dit
elle mais ce n'est pas possible je suis
né et j'ai grandi ici
mes parents sont morts ici parfois je
rêve qu'une vague géante mon porte c'est
une image qui me hantera toujours taper
pour ce jeune indonésien
les premières années après le tsunami
ont été très dures je pleurais presque
tous les jours dit il mais je suis
reconnaissant aux personnes qui m'ont
aidé à m'en remettre
aujourd'hui des cérémonie oecuménique se
tiennent dans les temples les églises et
les mosquées à la mémoire des victimes
le gouvernement thaïlandais dit vouloir
relever les normes en matière de
sécurité afin de préparer de protéger
les populations contre les catastrophes
le 26 décembre est décrétée journée
nationale de la prévention des accidents
sept médecins légistes thaïlandais
affirme que le pays ne pourra pas faire
face à une nouvelle catastrophe
naturelle mais et souligne que les
thaïlandais se sont toujours montrés
volontaires dans les crises
[Musique]
si certains survivants se sont réfugiés
dans la prière déry setiawan s'est jeté
dans les vagues pour guérir ses
blessures après le tsunami
il est devenu surfeurs professionnels et
sur sa planche
il tient un étal au seyant qui engloutit
son village et emporté plusieurs membres
de sa famille aujourd'hui on est
toujours là sur la côte
on ne peut pas partir c'est là où nous
vivons ici hasmik rails at radio canada
montréal